[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: We wanted
to really kick it off
with a taste of what
the magazine is like.
So we're going to
hear a quick reading
from Gary over here who was a
contributor to the first issue.
And he's going to read you
a part of his contribution
to the magazine.
Woo-hoo!
[LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
GARY YEH: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[LAUGHTER]
GARY YEH: So I'll
be reading excerpts
from my piece called "Depression
and the Art That Saved Me."
"I was 14 when I first felt
the urge to end my own life.
Most mornings, I would wake
up feeling cold and unwanted.
Even in the spring when the
dogwood tree outside my window
blossomed, I struggled to
find beauty in the world,
to motivate myself
to get out of bed.
Although there were
spurts of happiness,
my teenage years were haunted
by the desire to call it quits.
I struggled with my emotions,
but more importantly, I
struggled with why.
Why did I feel these urges?
Why was I unhappy?
For years, I tried
answering these questions,
and wondered if my
parents' rocky marriage
or my failed two-week
middle school relationship
factored into my depression.
As I entered high
school, however, I
began to realize that these
contortions of the mind
were rooted in an
internal struggle
with my race and my identity.
I grew up in a predominantly
white community.
I surrounded myself
with white friends.
I ignored our
differences in race,
and fundamentally, our
differences in culture.
And I sacrificed an
important part of myself
to blend in among my peers.
I ate different foods at
home than I did at school.
I was annoyed when my
parents mispronounced
basic English words,
yet I would shamelessly
laugh when white students
made mocking impersonations
of other Asians.
I wondered whether
my true self was
the person I was at home,
the person I was at school,
or neither.
I remember a time when I was
flipping through movie channels
and lingered on a Jackie
Chan film, a scene where
he was distressed and exclaimed
in a heavy accent, "Who am I?"
It was branded in
my mind for years.
Who am I?
A major challenge of my
depression was desensitization.
In order to cope with
suicidal thoughts,
I largely ignored them.
I set my emotions aside
and put on a plastic smile
wherever I went.
Over time, not only
did I become an expert
at hiding how I felt
inside, but I also
became incapable of
letting my emotions flow.
For years I never cried, despite
how desperately I begged to.
I lost the sensation
of being human
and felt completely out
of touch with my emotions.
One summer during
high school, my dad
dropped me off on the National
Mall in Washington, DC.
Go explore, he said, as
he drove off to work.
I loathed the experience.
I wanted to spend my summer
at home playing "Call of Duty"
or aimlessly scrolling
through Facebook.
After a few days
wandering through museums
of natural history,
airplanes, and design,
I eventually stumbled
into the Hirshhorn,
a Smithsonian Museum dedicated
to modern and contemporary art.
On view was an Yves
Klein retrospective,
highlighted by monochromes
and blue impressions
of the female body
pulled across canvas.
Searching for meaning
in these paintings
sparked a sense of
curiosity, and what I
would later discover to
be a sense of purpose.
I devoted the remainder
of my high school years
pursuing my fledgling
interest in the arts
to see how far I could take it.
Fortunately, my parents
supported this move,
because they thought
it would make
me a unique candidate
when it came time
for college applications.
[LAUGHTER]
In fact, the focus
shifted from making
sure I had good grades in
calculus and statistics
to allowing me to curate my
identity around the arts,
in order to "stand out" from
the Asians who had perfect SAT
scores.
I enrolled in AP art
history and subsequently
in independent study.
But something was still missing.
Academia bored me.
I was never satisfied
simply reading about it.
Plus, for however
much I loved art,
studying art at a suburban high
school where the jocks still
ruled supreme was perceived
as less than cool.
I continued living
as an outsider, not
fully in the Asian community,
and not fully in any other.
Even as I pursued what I
loved, I still felt alone.
At Duke University,
that sentiment
persisted into my
sophomore year.
I was the only male art history
major and the only minority
in my class.
Even though I had found a group
of like-minded individuals,
I couldn't get over how
different I was on the surface.
Searching for an
escape, I proceeded
with the only
millennial thing to do,
and I created an Instagram.
It became my diary.
My Instagram @artdrunk
began as a means
to document artwork
I liked, hated,
and everything in between.
Ultimately, I realized
it was an outlet
for communicating my emotions.
What I posted in
this digital world
often reflected how I felt in
real time and in real life.
Posting a Lucio Fontana,
an Italian artist
known for slashing
into canvases,
reflected one of my troubled
moments and my connection
with the rawness of breaking
an otherwise perfect surface.
Posting a Richard Serra,
an American sculptor
known for massive
expanses of steel,
reflected how I enjoyed
feeling human again
under a towering wall of metal,
and knowing that it would
exist centuries beyond my life.
As my Instagram following grew,
so did my sense of purpose.
Although the challenges
of being Asian American
in a white community and the
additional struggle of being
a minority in the arts have
made me feel different,
I believe that my race
does not define me.
It is only a part of my identity
rather than the whole of it.
I continue to engage
with my heritage,
learning about
different Asian teas,
and being proud to hear Taiwan
become the first Asian country
to legalize gay marriage.
But through art, I am empowered
to push beyond stereotypes.
It has helped me
create an identity
for myself not restricted
by the color of my skin
or the way my eyes
squint when I smile.
My battle with depression
lasted seven years,
which transformed the way I
view the world and the people
around me.
Those seven years
took me down a road
where I thought the darkness
would never turn to light.
But eventually,
those seven years
brought me to my
foremost passion.
Through the struggle,
I found art.
And in a very real and
literal sense, art saved me.
Without it, I would
still be lost,
trying to understand what
it means to be different
and what it means to be me."
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much.
That was an awesome reading.
And we're going to
get to hear from Gary
about that piece in a bit.
Perfect.
All right.
I'm excited to introduce
our panel here today.
Just going to do some quick
bios so we have some context.
Directly to my right--
[LAUGHTER]
--is our two founders,
Katerina and Krystie.
Katerina is a product
strategist in the tech industry,
and has worked from
companies actually
ranging from Yahoo to
early-stage Silicon Valley
startups.
She's passionate about music,
about making topics like race
and identity easier to talk
about in our everyday lives,
and has a bachelor's of arts in
English and music from Cornell.
Krystie is a creative strategist
at Landor, a global brand
consultancy, and serves
on the National Advisory
Board of Answer, a sex
education nonprofit,
that provides pro bono
consulting services
to women-led organizations.
She is an avid storyteller
who hopes to one day
perform at The Moth, and holds
a dual degree in business
administration and public
health from UC Berkeley.
Tessa is actually the
creative-- sorry, what was it?
Marketing director?
TESSA KU: Head of Digital.
SPEAKER 1: Head of Digital.
Yes.
Sorry.
Head of Digital.
The person who knows what
Instagram photos are coming up
from this event, essentially.
We planned that out earlier.
She's spent the last
five years here at NYC,
putting her marketing
degree to use.
We actually talked
at lunch about how
she's the only one of us who
actually uses her degree.
[LAUGHTER]
And currently leads luxury
marketing for the ad sales
department at the
"Wall Street Journal,"
as well as heading up the
digital efforts at "Slant'd."
Also perfecting
challah making skills,
which is pretty awesome.
TESSA KU: I just married
my Jewish husband,
so I'm working on perfecting
my perfecting my challah.
[LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Well, I personally know
that Asian-Jewish pairing
is a strong one.
So you know.
[LAUGHTER]
And then Gary, who
we just heard from,
is a Business Analyst for the
CIO at Fiserv Lending Solutions
and an aspiring art collector.
As you heard from his piece,
you can also follow him
on Instagram at @artdrunk.
So check that out
afterwards as well.
But I think I wanted
to kick it off kind
of by hearing first of all
from our two founders here
about how you would define,
like, what Slant'd is,
and what inspired
you to found it.
KATERINA JENG: Yeah.
I can sort of tell
the origin story.
So "Slant'd" is a
media company that
celebrates
Asian-American identity
through personal storytelling.
And it came about
because Krystie
invited me to a Facebook group
called Project Boat, which
was just a place for
people, Asian Americans,
to post about what's going on
in the news, ask for advice,
and just have a community
of like-minded people.
And I saw all these
amazing stories happening,
but they were happening in
this private Facebook group.
And I was like, this needs
to be out into the world.
So I was like, hey, Krystie,
you want to start a zine?
And we had, like, a
humble spreadsheet
where people were just dropping
in ideas of what stories
they might want to contribute.
And then from there, we launched
our Kickstarter campaign
in June, which got
such amazing support.
And that funded the Issue
01, which is on sale today.
And then for the launch
party for Issue 01,
we really felt just such an
amazing sense of community.
Like, we had a
sold-out launch party.
The energy and the support
was just so incredible.
And at that moment,
we were like,
this is way bigger
than a magazine.
So we've decided to
be a media company
and explore new forms
of media in 2018.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
KRYSTIE MAK: And a big
part of that too is I
went to a book talk
with Eddie Huang
about six months before
"Slant'd" became something.
And he said that if spaces
don't exist for you,
kick the door down
and create them.
And at that time,
we didn't even know
this was going to be a thing.
And when Kat reached
out to me, it just
felt like the right opportunity.
Because we didn't see ourselves
in media or in mainstream
media.
We wanted a place where
we could share our stories
from everyday people.
So one of the big things about
"Slant'd" is that it's not
celebrities who write for us.
You know, it's not
published writers, per se.
It's people like you, me,
your brother, your sister,
your cousin who just
have a story to tell,
and they just want a
place to share that
and to connect
with other people.
So "Slant'd's" really supposed
to be a community building,
creative outlet for all of us.
All of us were friends
when we started this,
so I think that's what
makes it extremely special.
SPEAKER 1: Definitely.
And so I mean, touching on that
point of the idea of building
a community, I mean,
I feel like one thing
we talk about with the
Asian Google Network a lot
is that there is very
little consensus on what it
means to be Asian American.
You know, that term
encompasses in theory, like,
hundreds of different
ethnicities and languages.
There's also the
question of citizens
and non-citizen
residents of the US
who are impacted by issues
that affect the community,
but may not have
been here as long,
or may not be here forever.
How do you guys sort
of define that idea
of an Asian-American
identity for the purposes
of the magazine.
KATERINA JENG: So
for the magazine,
we define Asian American as
anyone who has come from Asia.
So including East
Asian, Southeast Asian,
and South Asian.
And there are a lot
of different groups.
And our goal is not to
sort of lump everyone
into one category.
It's more to celebrate
the differences
that we all have and the shared
experiences that we do have.
I think one thing that the
Asian-American movement is
getting better at is being in
solidarity with each other.
Because in the past we've been
very separated, just thinking
about our history in America.
Coming to America,
no ethnic group
wanted to associate themselves
with another ethnic group that
had already come, because
they wanted to not face
the same discrimination.
But now, like, I feel since the
'90s and coming into the 2000s,
we're really starting
to come together.
And we're realizing that
together, we are stronger
and we can make a difference
as one whole collective.
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah,
and being this, like,
hyphenated culture has been
an interesting thing for us
at "Slant'd," because when we
edit a lot of the pieces from
Issue 01, a very common theme
was straddling two worlds.
So straddling what
it's like to be Asian,
what it's like to be American,
not fitting in either place.
And that's something
that I think
we wrestle with individually
and collectively as a community.
So when we look
for contributors,
we're looking for people who are
exploring this question of what
it means to be Asian American.
It's not a 50/50 split.
It's just an ongoing journey.
And everyone on
this team is also
going through a sense of
self-discovery in the process.
SPEAKER 1: So when
you were crafting
this first issue
of the magazine,
how did you go about
sourcing different voices
and different parts of the
Asian-American community?
KATERINA JENG: So it was a
pretty grassroots effort.
We had a Google
Form that we just
sent out to friends and family.
Great way of
collecting information.
[LAUGHTER]
And from there, we made sure
that every piece had a mission,
that the author had
something that they
wanted to say to the community.
And the theme of our first
issue was beginnings.
So whether that's a spiritual
beginning or a self-awakening
or the start of
something new, we
wanted to make sure that every
piece related to the theme.
KRYSTIE MAK: Mm-hmm.
And we purposely tried
to keep it very open.
You know, it's very
interpretive for each person.
And we looked to get people
from all over the country.
So although we're in New York
City right now on this event,
our contributors come from
all across the country.
We had 21 for this first
issue, and we actually only
knew seven of them beforehand.
We don't know how they found us.
I think it was
through word of mouth,
but that speaks to the
solidarity of our community,
just looking for a place
to share their stories.
SPEAKER 1: Interesting.
Tessa, I know we
were talking earlier
about balancing the
fact that you guys have
put so much work into
launching this while also
having these amazing careers
in tech and in marketing,
and all of these other things.
So I'd like to hear from
all of you, I guess,
about what it's been like
balancing a passion project
and starting a new media
company with having
these full-time other jobs.
TESSA KU: Yeah.
I mean, it's a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, the journal was going
through a reorg at the time
that things were
really ramping up.
And like, I was
planning my wedding
and we were launching this.
And it was like--
there were times where I
was, like, very stressed out.
But I think that this is a
situation in which the phrase
passion project is really
very applicable, because some
of my friends and I
have started projects
where we were really into
them, but they never really
went anywhere.
Because you know, like,
if things came up,
it kind of took a backseat.
But this is the kind of
project where for me, it
meant something very personal.
So I was able to
kind of prioritize it
over certain other things,
because it meant so much to me,
and it meant so much to
everyone else who was doing it.
KRYSTIE MAK: I was actually
talking to Gary about this
this morning.
I feel very lucky that I hit
my quarter-life breakthrough
shortly before starting
"Slant'd" where up until then
I kept thinking my job
had to be my calling,
had to be my passion,
had to be my everything.
And then I realized that
it didn't have to be that.
It didn't have to put so
much pressure on my job
being something bigger
than what it really was.
And so I happened to land
a job, a 9:00 to 5:00,
that truly was essentially
a 9:00 to 5:00.
And I love what I do.
I love doing branding.
And the company is
really supportive
of me doing side
projects like this.
And so the epiphany of having a
job that supports me in the way
that it allows me
to do something
like "Slant'd" or
pursuing a passion project
is really pivotal.
We joke that "Slant'd"
is like a second job,
and I definitely would not
have been able to do it
if it wasn't for the support
of my current company.
SPEAKER 1: That was
a good pivot there,
because I was like, uh-oh.
She's going, oh, yeah.
It's not a really a passion
of mine, 9:00 to 5:00.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
KRYSTIE MAK: It definitely is.
It's a 5:00 to 9:00 for sure,
but it's a very loving piece
of my 5:00 to 9:00.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
KRYSTIE MAK: I can't
imagine any other team
to do this with either.
I think the passion
that we all have,
the personal drive is
a really big factor.
SPEAKER 1: So what
kinds of things
have you done to sort of raise
awareness of the magazine,
and go out and spread
the word that there
is this new voice
in the landscape?
KATERINA JENG: I think
right now, most of it
has been word of mouth, which
just is a testament to how
strong the community is.
Our biggest channel
right now is Instagram
I think us being millennials,
it was a natural outlet for us
to speak directly
to our audience.
But in the new
year, in 2018, we're
going to be looking
at events hopefully
across the country, more
marketing on social media
channels, and paid
advertising as well.
KRYSTIE MAK: And also just
co-creation or collaborative
events, or even initiatives.
So we've been very active about
going to other events, meeting
people.
Not just Asian Americans, but
other communities of color
to see what types of events
they're interested in,
what kind of dialogue
they want to be a part of,
and how we can really raise
awareness in that way.
Because something we
discovered at the launch party
was that this isn't just
for Asian Americans.
Like, we are a
platform specifically
to elevate the
Asian-American narrative,
but it's a broader
immigrant story.
And in that sense, I
think we have the power
to really make a stronger impact
by collaborating with others.
SPEAKER 1: So has
your idea of what
representation
looks like changed
as you formed the magazine?
Or what do you see yourselves
highlighting or really
elevating thematically
in the future?
KATERINA JENG: I think so.
So one thing that was
an interesting shift
is when we first
started "Slant'd," we
thought we would
create a community
to bring like-minded
people together.
And then after the
election happened
and seeing the divisiveness
within our country,
we realized that we
don't need to bring
similar people together.
We need to bring
different people together,
and people with
different experiences,
cultural backgrounds,
and perspectives,
and show that even
though you are different,
you can still be friends.
And in the end, we all share
the same fundamental stories
of being a human.
TESSA KU: I think it's also
kind of like a cultural movement
that's happening that
we are just a part of.
I think that you can
see that in Hollywood
where the people
are speaking out
against the whitewashing
of Asian roles
and traditionally Asian movies,
or like the "Hawaii Five-0"
cast walking when they
weren't paid equally.
Just all sorts of
things like that
are really coming
to the surface now,
and I think that's what
makes our platform especially
relevant and especially needed.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Has that been, like, a
big reaction from people
is that specifically, they talk
about Hollywood whitewashing
or representation in media
when they talk to you guys
about what they want to see?
KATERINA JENG: We do
get a lot of questions,
like, any time we talk to
press about things going on
in the media.
But it's interesting, because
it's not just about that.
Like, the story
is so much larger,
and we're just one
piece of the puzzle that
needs to happen in order to
push the movement forward.
KRYSTIE MAK: I think
also because we're
rooted in personal storytelling,
so the questions that we get
or the topics that we get fished
for are a little bit deeper
than that.
I mean, they definitely
cover our representation
in media or lawsuits per se.
But one of the things that
really struck home for us
was a lot of reaching out
from families who adopt
Asian kids into their families.
And that's a story
that personally I
haven't explored yet.
I would love to explore
in future issues.
But just these open questions
about, what do we do?
How do we talk about
race and identity
with our kids who grew up
looking different than us?
And so it's a very sensitive
piece to talk about,
but I think that's
something that we can do.
We can create a safe space for
that conversation to happen.
SPEAKER 1: That's
really interesting
that that's kind of the audience
that's surfaced for you guys.
Do you have-- do you feel like
you have a response for that?
Or is there kind of
a sense of, well, we
can't define for you what your
child's Asian identity is?
KATERINA JENG: Right.
Obviously, that's a
very big role to fill.
But I do think these
everyday stories can help.
Like, I'm thinking of
when I was growing up,
did I have a
magazine that I could
pick up and read about other
Asian-American experiences?
I didn't really have
anything like that.
So
"Slant'd" could be something
for that lone kid in Arkansas
who might not have a
community that looks like him
or goes through the same
experiences that he does.
For him to pick it up
and say, wow, there
are other people that
can relate to what's
happening to my experience.
KRYSTIE MAK: As well
as act as a resource.
So like, we're definitely not
the authority on anything.
Like, the Asian-American
narrative, per se.
But every time we talk to
someone, they get so excited
and want to connect us with five
more people in the community.
So maybe we can't speak about
that story in particular,
but maybe we can connect
them with someone
who can put them in
touch with someone else
or share their own story.
SPEAKER 1: Definitely.
So in that sense, what has
been your vision of like--
I know you were
saying you actually
decided to become a
more full-rounded media
company rather than a magazine.
Is that where the idea comes
from, is creating resources?
KRYSTIE MAK: Not necessarily
just for resources.
I think it's to expand
the reach and realizing
that stories come in many
different shapes and sizes
and forms.
We've gotten so much
clamor about digital.
I am a die-hard
paper fan, but I do
recognize that in
the 21st century,
digital is really critical.
TESSA KU: They can
both work together.
KRYSTIE MAK: They
can work together.
[LAUGHTER]
So figuring out how we
can create more platforms
for storytelling, because we
were created to fill a need,
and we can't just fill that
need with paper or with print.
KATERINA JENG: Also
the fact that we
want to create a community
that has a two-way dialogue.
So whereas putting out a
magazine and having someone
consume it is more of
a one-way conversation,
we really want to
create spaces where
people can interact
with the content
and interact with
each other, and start
to talk about these
issues that are
so complicated and nuanced
that really need discussion
around it in order to
move things forward.
TESSA KU: Yeah, I think
that especially today,
like, if we are trying to reach
that lone kid in Arkansas who
doesn't have any Asian
friends or an Asian community,
like, an online
presence that's robust
and really a community in
itself is so important.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
So it sounds like you guys
do an amazing job of kind
of giving a voice to people
like that who don't feel they
have a community currently.
But on the flip side, like,
I was talking to a friend
recently who mentioned
that he really
thinks of himself more as Asian
rather than Asian American,
and that if he wanted to
see himself represented
in the media, he could
watch Chinese movies
and read Chinese books.
Do you see a divide there
between the experiences
of more recent Asian
immigrants or maybe even
non-permanent residents who
are in the States for now
versus sort of American-born
or American-raised Asian
Americans?
Asians?
[LAUGH]
KRYSTIE MAK: [INAUDIBLE].
GARY YEH: I think
there's actually--
from my experience, it's
been quite a difference
where going to a school
like Duke University,
there are a lot of
international students.
And of course, some from
China, some from Korea,
some from the Middle East.
But I think the very nature
of being international and not
coming into a country
and having to find people
that are like you, they
sort of group themselves
off very quickly, and they
form their own communities.
And so whereas for me,
like, being Asian American,
growing up in predominantly
white communities,
I was much more--
not to say that they're
not open to that,
but I was already sort
of in those groups
and in those communities,
whereas there was definitely
that divide between the two.
And I think for me
as an Asian American,
it's almost difficult to
connect with other Asians
actually from Asia
or born in Asia.
TESSA KU: Yeah, I think to that
point an interesting-- like,
not a trend, but a pattern
that's emerged, I think,
in our conversations and
in the stories that we hear
is that you have this
unique position where you're
kind of too Asian
to be American,
but you're too
American to really
be Asian to people
who live in Asia.
So being Asian American is this
really interesting place to be.
And like for me personally
when I was younger,
I didn't want to have
anything to do with it
so I would ignore all
my Chinese homework
and I hated my Chinese
lessons, and now I
don't know how to speak
Mandarin, which I really
regret.
So if I were looking for more
Asian representation in media,
like, I wouldn't be able
to watch Chinese movies
or read Chinese books.
I would just-- I'm looking
for Asian representation
in American media.
So I think it's a really
unique thing to you,
and how deep your connection
is to your Asian heritage.
KRYSTIE MAK: I think
part of the divide,
though, some of the
cause potentially
could be we gravitate
towards people who
give us a sense of belonging.
And so as Asian
Americans, maybe we
gravitate more towards
Asian Americans
because we get the traditions
that they're observing
or the food that they're eating.
And people coming from
another country potentially,
they can't speak the
language, and they
feel a sense of belonging
within a specific group.
And so it almost
feels like a sense
of survival tactic in a way.
I would love to break
down that divide.
We've talked about
the hierarchies
within Asian-American culture.
That's something we
definitely want to explore.
Because again, Asian American
isn't just East Asian.
And so what does that
hierarchy look like,
and how we can start
to break that down
and to really connect on a
more human level beyond race.
KATERINA JENG: Yeah.
And I think that would
be the ultimate goal,
is to break down that
barrier between Asian
Americans and Asians.
Because if we're all
living in America,
then we can all benefit from
having a more solid community.
SPEAKER 1: Do you
see any value then
in doing, like,
multilingual content
or having people from all these
different ethnic and language
groups who are
contributing doing
stuff that's maybe
translated in both languages,
or anything like that?
KATERINA JENG: That
would be amazing.
[LAUGHTER]
Once we have the resources.
KRYSTIE MAK: And yeah.
And to Tessa's point,
like, I personally
can't read Mandarin--
or read Chinese.
I would love to be able to.
Another regret also, going
to 10 years of Chinese school
and not studying hard.
I would love to able
to translate that,
because we've gotten
actually inquiries
from folks who don't
live in the US.
So we were trying to
figure out, as a startup,
like, how do we ship
to another country?
How do we translate things
in another language?
But that would be amazing
if we could do that.
GARY YEH: I think
to that question,
I don't know if any of you
guys saw the most recent show
at the Guggenheim.
So it's a exhibition
on Chinese art.
And I think as someone who
appreciates art and has
studied art in school,
I was really surprised
to find how different it was
to look at art that was-- you
know, we see a lot of text
art, but text art that
was Chinese-based and based
off of Chinese characters.
And that gave me really
a newfound appreciation
for what art could be.
And if we did have
stories in different text,
obviously, different languages
have different nuances
to the actual word.
Like, there are
a lot of words we
can't express in Chinese that
we do express in English,
and vice versa.
And so if there are ways
to actually integrate that,
that would be great.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
No, that's really interesting.
I mean, I definitely
see the challenge.
I also don't speak any Chinese.
[LAUGH]
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah,
like, as the editors,
it's like, how would we edit
this in a different language?
SPEAKER 1: Right.
Yeah.
Very big deal in my family
that I took Japanese in college
instead.
[LAUGH]
KRYSTIE MAK: You're a bad Asian.
[INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: Don't you
have a hashtag for that?
KATERINA JENG: Yeah, #BadAsians.
SPEAKER 1: #BadAsians.
Gary, kind of speaking to your
art experience and stuff, like,
how did you actually first come
to get involved with "Slant'd?"
And how did you
choose that piece
as what you wanted to
contribute for this first issue?
GARY YEH: Yeah.
So my sister Lena, she's
actually involved with
the founding of "Slant'd."
I think she was the
partnership director.
KRYSTIE MAK: She's
our hustler in chief.
GARY YEH: OK.
KRYSTIE MAK: She handled
a lot of the partnerships
that we had.
GARY YEH: Yeah.
And so she-- I guess when they
were looking for contributors,
naturally she just reached
out to me, and I signed on.
That's the story for that.
But in terms of
the actual piece,
initially, I was going
to write about being
a minority in the
contemporary art world
where there honestly
aren't that many.
Especially in scenes
like New York and London,
it's hard to find Asians who are
at the top of the gallery chain
or the top of being
good collectors.
So that's what I thought about.
But I mean, Kat and Krystie
can really attest to this,
where I really struggled
with that topic.
And I spent two months writing
it, sending back drafts
and missing deadlines
here and there.
[LAUGHTER]
And eventually, I wanted
to write something
a little more personal.
And this piece had always
been in the back of my mind
of accepting that I
had a mental illness.
And I think writing
it down really
was that way of expressing,
you know, this is who I am.
So be it.
I want to share that
story, and really
try to just share it with other
people who might connect to it.
KATERINA JENG: And I thought
that was an amazing shift,
because it was actually a
completely different piece
than what we were
first working on.
And mental illness is something
that really isn't spoken
about in Asian communities.
So we have a couple pieces
on depression and overcoming
mental illness in a very
traditional household in Issue
01.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I completely agree.
I mean, it's just not--
it's not considered
acceptable in a lot of ways.
Yeah.
So have you had any
specific reaction
from readers about those
pieces in particular?
KRYSTIE MAK: About the mental
health stuff, definitely
a few folks.
One of my old roommates,
actually, she's
very open about mental
health, and she's actually
thinking about going and
becoming a psychotherapist.
And she read that
piece and was really
happy that she saw that piece.
Like, saw Gary's piece.
Because she is excited
about the prospect of people
coming to terms with that and
being able to openly share
that maybe they're not
done overcoming it yet,
and that they're
starting to seek help.
And just seek a community
to have a conversation with
was really interesting.
But there are other themes
within the first issue
that really resonated
with folks too.
There's one in particular about
an Indian American woman who
renounced her Indian citizenship
to take on US citizenship.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, interesting.
KRYSTIE MAK: And she
talks about that struggle
all her life growing up,
wanting to be American,
wanting to go to prom
and driving a Range
Rover with her friends,
going to the mall.
And then finally when
it comes down to it
and she has to renounce
her Indian citizenship,
she feels this overwhelming
sense of sadness
that she has let go of a part of
a culture or a part of herself
that for a long time
she was pushing aside.
And it doesn't matter
what race you are.
Like, being able to let go
of something from the past
to [INAUDIBLE] to
something in the future
is really interesting.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, definitely.
I mean, I already
want to read this,
because that's something my
family actually went through.
My mom was originally Malaysian.
And after my sister was
born, she was like, ugh,
I guess I'm staying.
[LAUGHTER]
But had to renounce
citizenship for that.
So in terms of the more--
beyond community
building, I feel
like it's almost
like a political act
to create an
Asian-American magazine,
because there has
been so little media
attention around the
Asian-American community.
Do you guys see yourself as a
political force in some way?
KATERINA JENG: That's
an interesting question,
because when we first
founded it, I would say no.
But now I would say
it's inevitable.
And I personally,
and I know a lot
of the people on
the "Slant'd" team
has been really aware of
just the words that we use,
making sure that everything
we say is politically correct,
being educated, and
reading up as much
as we can on
Asian-American history
and what our people
have been through.
It's just inevitably tied
to the political sphere.
And so I think all of us are on
that journey to becoming more
politically aware and present.
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah,
and everything
is political these days.
So whether or not--
as much as you say something
or don't say something,
it's political.
And I think our
name is really bold,
and I think that's
important to recognize,
because we're going
to be unapologetically
bold about these stories.
And I think in year
2, we're really
looking to do that
a little bit more.
You know, finding
stories that really
push the conversation to be a
platform for Asian Americans,
not just about Asian Americans.
So yeah.
I would say that we could
be a political force,
but we need the community
behind us to do that.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
Do you find the community
sort of divided?
I mean, I think my impression
of the Asian-American community
is like we have so
many different issues.
Like, for instance, you know,
Asian members of the community
face very different issues
in terms of racial profiling
and stuff that an East Asian--
has it been hard to create a
unifying force or a unifying
voice in that sense?
KATERINA JENG: I
think that's something
that we're going to be working
on for years and years to come.
Like, we're still not there.
And it's about both celebrating
all these differences
and the different
maybe stereotypes
that each group might face,
the different experiences
that we all might go
through, and saying
that even though we have all
these different experiences,
we can still relate
to each other.
SPEAKER 1: Can you talk
a little bit about-- you
mentioned the choice of
the name for the magazine.
[LAUGH]
KATERINA JENG: Yeah.
It's funny because
we didn't think
it was so controversial until
we actually pushed it out there.
And we get comments
about it all the time.
But there's a couple
different meanings behind it.
One that I love to talk
about is we really want
to shift people's perspectives.
So putting a slant on something
or putting a tilt on something
and getting people to
see things in a new light
is really what the name
"Slant'd" is about.
And the fact that it's
unapologetically bold,
and we want to spark
those conversations.
Our name is definitely
a conversation starter
and something that leads
to deeper conversations.
KRYSTIE MAK: Another
thing you had
touched on earlier is the
nuance and the diversity
of the Asian-American community.
So the term slanted is
often used as a blanket term
to characterize all
Asian Americans.
But that's not fair,
because the origins actually
come from East Asian features.
So what we wanted
to do was reclaim
this term and to
actually make it
a term that we can celebrate.
And so that's a little bit
about what we are about,
which is celebrating
Asian-American diversity
and identity.
So we wanted a name
to characterize that.
And when we first started,
actually half the team
was not on board with this name.
[LAUGHTER]
We had funny names.
We had a lot of cutesy names.
KATERINA JENG: Mm-hmm.
A lot of food-related--
KRYSTIE MAK: Food-related ones.
And now I don't even
think twice about it.
Now I love that term
so much, I don't even
think about the
derogatory nature of it.
And I think that
speaks a lot to what
we're trying to accomplish.
SPEAKER 1: Did you follow
at all that there was
a lawsuit related to this name?
Yeah.
Does anyone want to explain
more context on that?
TESSA KU: Essentially, there
was this Asian-American rock
band called The
Slants, and they were
trying to trademark their name.
And the Patent and
Trademark Office
wouldn't allow it,
because they said it was
discriminatory towards Asians.
And they were like,
but we're Asian--
[LAUGHTER]
--and we want it.
So isn't this a freedom
of speech situation?
And eventually-- and it weirdly
happened to be at the same time
of launch--
the Supreme Court
ruled in their favor,
in the favor of The
Slants so that they
could have that name trademarked
and take back ownership the way
that we are.
But it was so funny,
because everyone was like,
have you heard?
Is this from the same thing?
And we're like, no.
It's like purely coincidental.
But I think, you
know, it kind of--
it provides even
more support for it,
because it's just
like the universe is--
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah,
the universe--
TESSA KU: --working
in that favor.
[LAUGH]
KRYSTIE MAK: And
actually, it was funny,
because we want to say that
we're friends with them
now, because we
support each other.
We talked about them
on our Instagram.
They gave us a
shout-out as well.
I think it's, again, speaking
to the power of the community
that when you find something
or people who understand what
you're going through
or they just get it,
there's an unspoken
relationship there
that I think keeps blossoming.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
Now was interesting.
I remember thinking the case
itself was really interesting
as well, because there was
this freedom of speech idea of,
well, are you allowed
to reclaim this term?
But I did see someone
bring up alternatively
that because the Supreme Court
decided in favor of that band
that also the
Washington Redskins get
to keep their name as well.
[LAUGH]
TESSA KU: Yeah.
Kind of of a double-edged sword.
And it was interesting, because
I was re-watching this Trevor
Noah segment on it last
night, where the Patent
Office basically
told The Slants,
like, if you weren't
Asian, you would
be able to trademark this name.
But because you're
Asian, it gives
the discriminatory context.
And the guy who was
hosting the segment
was basically like, so in
saying that this is a--
like, they're trying to protect
you from racial discrimination,
they discriminated
against you racially.
How does that make sense?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
KRYSTIE MAK: The
world's a crazy place.
SPEAKER 1: Right?
[LAUGH]
That's so funny.
So what about transitioning
from the Redskins
away from horrible,
un-PC things too.
Like, how do you
guys feel you've
been trying to reach across the
aisle to maybe other minority
groups and stuff as well?
KATERINA JENG: So I think that's
where our partnerships come in.
We've been going
to a lot of events
and meeting other people
of color in this space
and figuring out what
we can do next year
to create more
community spaces that
are inclusive of all races.
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah.
Specifically, I was telling
the team over the weekend about
a people of color in solidarity
storytelling event that I had
been to in Brooklyn--
of course Brooklyn--
two weeks ago.
And it was interesting to
have a conversation of what
people of color really means.
Traditionally, at least
personally, I never
felt like I fit into that
category of a person of color.
And it was actually
hosted by folks
who have Latin American roots,
and they had a very interesting
take on this too.
They were quiet for a
lot of the session, a lot
of the storytelling session.
And one of them came forward and
said, I'm sorry I'm so quiet.
It's because for
the first time, I'm
realizing that I
wasn't including Asian
Americans in this conversation.
I wasn't including them in
this conversation of what
people of color really means.
And I really appreciated that
honesty and that vulnerability,
and that's something
that we believe in too.
And I think it's good
for us to keep ourselves
accountable and honest.
And when we say Asian
American, what does that mean?
And when we say immigrant
story, what does that mean?
I think it's going to
be a constant learning
opportunity for
us and a great way
for us to stay honest
with ourselves.
SPEAKER 1: Do you
see that separation
of the Asian-American community
from other people of color as,
like, imposed on
us by other groups,
or something we
impose on ourselves?
KRYSTIE MAK: I
imagine it's both.
I think there's a
lot of stereotypes
about Asian Americans, right?
That we're quiet, that we don't
like to speak up for things,
we stay in the foreground--
or the background.
I'm seeing every day
that that's changing.
And again, there's a piece in
our Issue 01 that talks about
the political uprising of Asian
Americans where a lot of times
folks in the government
ignore us as a voting group.
They don't think that we like
to vote, that we have a voice,
and so they oversee
us or they neglect us.
You know, so some of it
may be true a little bit
where we're not maybe speaking
up as much as we would like,
but I think that's changing.
And I think given the
election and this fire that's
all been lit underneath us
to do something is really
changing that course.
SPEAKER 1: Tell us
a little bit about--
you chose this theme of
beginnings for the first issue.
I'd love to hear a little bit
about what that means to you,
and also what you kind of see
as being the next theme going
forward.
KATERINA JENG: So beginnings
was a natural theme for us,
because it was Issue 01.
So this was sort
of the beginning
of what "Slant'd" was.
But I think for a
lot of the team,
"Slant'd" was a
creative outlet for us
to explore our own identities.
I know for me
personally I grew up
in a predominantly
white community,
and I didn't start thinking
about my Asian-American
identity until
after college, which
is crazy, because all
of my formative years
have already passed.
So for me, "Slant'd" has
been a personal awakening
of discovering who I am
and my cultural heritage.
And I think a lot of the
team was along the same vein.
They were discovering
something about themselves too.
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah.
I mean, beginnings for
me was interesting too,
because I grew up in
the opposite situation
where my neighborhood
was predominantly Asian.
My high school was
64% Asian growing up.
So I never felt like a minority.
I went to Berkeley, which
was also full of Asians.
It wasn't actually until
I moved to New York
about three years ago
that I felt like an other,
or I felt like a minority.
Which to, I guess, not New
Yorkers seems kind of crazy,
because it's a diverse place.
But you know, the
conversations I
was having with friends, a lot
of whom are in the audience
today, talking about our
different experiences
really made me realize
that all of our beginnings
are so different, but we
share a lot of values.
And I really wanted to explore
that with this project.
TESSA KU: Yeah.
I think also the
theme as you'll, like,
read the pieces in
the issue, a beginning
means something
different to everyone.
So it's not even necessarily
the beginning of you,
like, welcoming your heritage
or realizing that you do fit in
or you don't fit in.
It's like, beginning to
form a tight relationship
with your mother, or like the
beginning of when you first
immigrated to America.
It means something
different for everyone.
And I think to be
able to explore
that was really cool to see
how everyone interpreted it.
SPEAKER 1: Have you ever had any
negative feedback from people?
KATERINA JENG: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Definitely.
As you said, like, whether
we intend for it or not,
everything is political.
So we've gotten negative
feedback about our name--
KRYSTIE MAK: Pushing
the envelope.
But you know, it's
not as much negative
as it is constructive criticism.
So we are very open to
feedback, and we definitely
ask people that we
talk to as mentors,
as advisors, as friends to
tell us how we can up our game.
And so with a
content perspective,
people really liked
how relatable it was.
But they were like,
well, given how bold
your name is, could you push the
content a little bit further?
Are there any other topics
that you could explore?
And I think that's great,
because we're so new
and we're so open to evolution.
And just-- we've only been
around for less than a year,
so I can only
imagine what's going
to happen in years two to five.
KATERINA JENG: Yeah.
And that's another thing that
I would love for "Slant'd"
to work on is the
fact that we do
get constructive criticism
shouldn't stop anyone
from talking about race.
Like, it is very scary
to talk about race.
You always need to be
politically correct, you
need to be educated
about what's going on,
which oftentimes prevents
people from being
open about talking about it.
But if we don't
talk about it, we're
not going to get anywhere.
So we really need to make it
more accessible for people
to talk about these
really difficult things,
and just be confident in where
they are in their own journeys.
SPEAKER 1: Definitely.
Let's take a question
from over there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
guys so much for coming.
It's truly inspiring.
I will 100% be purchasing
my first issue.
I was just thinking,
this is the perfect gift
for my little sister.
KRYSTIE MAK: Aw!
AUDIENCE: She's also half Asian.
So like, similar to me.
[LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: No, really?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But my
question is kind
of about this story
gathering piece,
and how you guys
actually get stories.
Do you guys just wait
for them to come in?
Do you guys put
certain posts out?
And on top of that,
how does choosing
the stories to go with
a certain theme, what
is that process like?
KRYSTIE MAK: You
want me to start?
KATERINA JENG: Sure.
KRYSTIE MAK: So you know,
like Kat said, we love Google.
We literally live and
die off of Google.
So we used a Google Form
to collect story ideas.
A lot of the stories
actually didn't end up
the way they started,
which we think
is a really beautiful
process, and we
want to do more
of that next year,
actually workshopping
the stories with people.
But we asked for an idea.
We ask again for
their objective, what
they want to achieve with it.
What's the key message?
And to get the word out, it
was friends, family, and fools,
and posting it in community
groups on Facebook.
So going into Asian-American
interest groups,
posting on there.
Project Boat, which we initially
started as a support group.
Alumni networks.
Basically anyone that we
thought might be interested.
The first two weeks
were very slow.
We were really worried
that we weren't going
to get anyone to contribute.
And I don't know.
Something just happened.
I think word of mouth.
You know, it's a very
grassroots movement.
And again, like, out
of the 21 contributors,
we only knew seven
of them beforehand.
So we're hoping that next year
it's probably a little bit more
strategic in that sense.
Hopefully, our name is
a little bit out there
and we can come out
to events like these
and meet more people who
would be interested in sharing
their stories.
AUDIENCE: Definitely.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: How should
people reach you
if they see this talk, for
example, on our YouTube channel
and they want to
be a part of it?
KATERINA JENG: Yeah.
You can visit our
website at slantd.media.
And we're opening the submission
window for Issue 02 in January.
So you can either sign up to
our newsletter to get an update
or just find us on social media.
We'll be very loud
when the window opens,
so you know to come
and submit your story.
SPEAKER 1: Is it all, like,
sort of personal essay pieces?
Or are there, like, poems,
journalistic pieces,
anything like that?
KATERINA JENG: It's a variety.
So we have short stories.
Just kidding.
We don't have short stories.
We have short pieces.
We have poetry,
photography, art.
It spans all genres.
KRYSTIE MAK: Anything
that could be printed.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
[LAUGH]
What about over here?
AUDIENCE: I just want
to say thank you again
for sharing your piece, Gary.
Like, I was very touched by it.
I'm a Chinese psychologist,
so I feel very strongly
about raising awareness
for Asian Americans.
So I was wondering if
you guys have any plans
or needing contributors or ways
to kind of bring the awareness
to the general community.
Because I think we all know
that Asian Americans tend
to solve problems
in their own house,
and I think needing to reach
them is still, like-- there's
still a huge gap.
So I was wondering if you
have any thoughts on that.
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah.
I mean, I think
we're exploring that.
But again, we're a
creative platform,
so how could we explore
the difficult topics
of mental health from
a creative perspective?
So could we host writing
workshops or town hall
discussions about this?
I think we can't do it alone,
and we're definitely not
experts in this field.
So we would love to
partner with people
who have experience in
the mental health space
to help us create a place
that's safe, you know,
that's relevant and
meaningful for these people.
GARY YEH: Yeah, I feel
like being so involved
with the arts, I've
realized there's
a lot of artists and a
lot of creative types
that have mental illness.
And I don't know if
they go hand in hand.
But when I first posted
my story on Instagram,
I was really surprised
by the outpour,
outpouring of
support and interest
in these sorts of stories.
And a lot of direct
messages just saying, hey.
This is-- thank you
for sharing this.
I've dealt with
depression myself.
My sister has dealt
with depression.
Whatever it may be, they
all had their own stories.
And again, I think this
is a great platform
to actually get the word out.
And with peripheral topics
like mental illness,
this is, again, a good
grounding and foundation
for those discussions
I have a couple questions
about contributing.
The first one is, I just visited
an Asian-American lit class
at a high school yesterday,
and they were all
really engaging writers.
So I want to know
if there is an age
limit to being a contributor.
KATERINA JENG: We have
not put an age limit.
It's something we
could consider,
but right now, anybody
is open to submitting.
AUDIENCE: And then
so along with that,
does that mean that you
have to identify as Asian
American to contribute?
That might be an obvious
question, but maybe not.
KATERINA JENG: So all of our
Issue 01 contributors were
Asian American, but we would be
open to any race contributing
as long as it aligns with
our mission and aligns with
the theme of Issue 02.
TESSA KU: Yeah, I
think it depends
on what the narrative is.
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah.
KATERINA JENG: Yeah.
KRYSTIE MAK: And
I think too, you
know, you bring up a good point
about talking to potentially
a younger audience.
The team struggled too
with trying to figure out,
who is our target audience?
You know, Asian
American is so big.
So millennials were
obviously an easy target,
because we're all millennials.
But there are so many
interesting stories coming out
from high schoolers
and even younger.
And so how could we go into
universities and high schools
to have this kind
of conversation?
So we would be really
interested in meeting people
in the younger
demographic to see what
issues they're dealing with.
And how could we give
them a space share that?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for being here, and
good luck on all the work
you're going to be doing.
So the topic about
translating submissions
reminded me a story
of-- my grandfather
started an academic journal
in Korea about, I guess,
nearly 50 years ago now.
And when he started it, he
just simply wanted people
to submit articles written in
English so that people outside
of Korea, academics outside
of Korea could read it
and understand what's going on.
So I guess it just brought
one thing is that there's
so many different
Asian, I guess,
American languages that English
just happens to be something
that is in common.
So I guess sometimes things
get lost in translation.
Maybe if the
submission is written
in the language they're
most comfortable with,
that might be ideal.
But I guess for maybe
the majority of people,
it would be, I
guess, just English.
And the second
question, do you guys
do anything with the
museums, like the Museum
of Chinese in America and
things like that in the city?
KATERINA JENG: Yeah.
We actually had our launch
party at the Museum of Chinese
in America, and we're
stocked there as well.
And we're definitely
looking to partner
with other museums and other
Asian-American organizations.
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah.
And [INAUDIBLE],, what
was your first question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, it wasn't
more of a question.
KRYSTIE MAK: Oh, just a comment?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
about-- yeah.
Just like similarly,
my grandfather
also started I guess
something like a zine back
in the day also--
[LAUGH]
--for political
science articles.
It's called the
"Korea Observer."
KRYSTIE MAK: "Korea Observer."
AUDIENCE: And it's, like,
you know, all the articles
in English so that his--
because he wanted
the audience to be
broader than just
people in Korea
just so everybody across
the world could read.
TESSA KU: I think the
topic of translation
is really interesting and
obviously, something that we're
excited about exploring.
But we want to be
able to do it right.
You know, we want to be able
to do the pieces justice.
Because if it is lost
in translation, then
what's the point in doing it?
AUDIENCE: Good luck
with everything.
GROUP: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
I think we didn't actually touch
on thoughts for the next issue.
KRYSTIE MAK: Oh.
Yeah.
Funny you ask, because we
just had our kick-off over
the weekend to start
thinking about Issue 02.
We haven't narrowed
down a theme yet,
but our creative team did a
really great job in the prompt.
So the prompt was
wishes and wonders.
So thinking about
reflecting on this past year
or almost a year, what do
we wish we had covered?
What are we wondering
about still today
about race and identity?
And there were a whole
swath of different options.
We had stuff that was very
universal to like what
they call the dark horse theme.
KATERINA JENG: Very niche.
KRYSTIE MAK: Very niche.
Very, very specific.
A little bit controversial.
I think-- huh?
TESSA KU: Ear wax.
KRYSTIE MAK: Ear wax.
[LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: What?
KRYSTIE MAK: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's a wide
range, and I think
we're going to land
somewhere in the middle.
I think we want a theme that's
universal enough that people
can interpret on their
own and make it their own,
but we also want something
that's not generic.
KATERINA JENG: And
I think two things
that we're looking for
in this next round is,
as Krystie mentioned, pushing
the envelope a little bit.
So because these are
everyday stories,
how can we elevate them and
make sure that they're worth
the buzz and worth sparking
those larger conversations?
And another thing is making
things a bit lighter.
So Issue 01 leaned on the more
heavier side, which is normal,
because the experiences that
we face as Asian Americans are
on the heavier side.
But how can we bring a
sense of fun and playfulness
back into talking about
these really heavy topics?
Will be interesting
for us to explore.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, definitely.
We're almost at time.
So my last question
is going to be,
we obviously want to sell some
of those magazines in the back,
you guys.
[LAUGHTER]
How would you pitch the magazine
to a non-Asian audience?
KATERINA JENG: Ooh.
That's a great question.
[LAUGH]
TESSA KU: I mean, I feel like
part of the appeal is that
it's--
don't know.
Like, I'm not
explaining myself right.
But I think that--
so my in-laws are not Asian,
but they were just so excited
that I was doing something
like this with my friends
that they were, like,
telling all their friends,
and they were buying
all these books.
And I think that just
the fact that it's
part of a movement that has
pieces that everyone can relate
to, I think everyone can
relate to at some point
feeling like they
don't belong somewhere
or wishing that
they were different
or connecting to their heritage.
I think that everyone has
some sort of connection
with what we're doing, which,
in a way, helps sell itself.
KRYSTIE MAK: I think it's
anchored in human emotion.
You know, there's
themes about sacrifice,
about love, about
realization, actualization.
Like, these are themes
that transcend race.
So I would say it's just a
fun, creative outlet for people
to read stories and learn
something about themselves
or learn something
about another culture.
And who doesn't want to do
that in this day and age,
given what's going on?
[APPLAUSE]
KATERINA JENG:
Thanks for having us.
KRYSTIE MAK: Thank you.
Thank you so much!
[LAUGH]